i've been very frustrated with the trend
of glorifying obesity in this country
and how magazine covers and the
television industry now in an effort to
make everyone feel comfortable in their
own skin has decided to ignore actual
health
and there's a glamorizing of you know
obesity is healthy and you know you see
people who are grossly obese on the
cover of a magazine and they're saying
this is healthy this is fit and it's not
reality is that they're predisposing
themselves to a number of health
conditions as a result of that behavior
as someone in the fitness industry how
do you deal with that that like does
that feel like a slap in the face to
what you're doing every day and how do
you manage those conversations with
people where you have to just be honest
about
weight and what it does to the body that
excess weight totally and i'll say like
i said in one of my posts this is one of
the things i'm like i'm tired of the
[ __ ] you know because it's like it's
gotten to the point where where
people
are just accepting being okay at a
weight that is unhealthy and it's
because of a lot of these agendas and
narratives that are constantly being
pushed down people's throats through
hollywood and media and magazines and tv
and all this stuff because we don't want
to hurt people's feelings and
everything's trigger friendly now and
everything's sensitive and it's like
look the whole thing about you know not
hurting people's feelings there's one
thing i said like in my post it's like
there's a difference between fat shaming
and glorifying obesity huge difference
right you know what i mean if i'm over
here bullying somebody because of their
weight then that's my problem that's me
who has to deal with whatever i'm
dealing with i shouldn't be doing that
but if i'm over here he's willing to
accept that i'm going to glorify and
sean maggie's in tv like embrace your
obesity embrace this embrace what do you
mean embrace this you're sending a bad
example to all the other people who are
overweight
all the children out there because now
you're getting more children who are
becoming overweight and obese you know
pediatric facilities like babies are
obese it's insane and it's sad because
it's like that's only driving the
country
down a spiral with your health we've
already been having an obesity issue for
a long time now and it's funny because
like for years we've always had that
obesity problem and you know fast food
issues and i feel like a lot of people
have been taking into account more than
health than before and all these more
holistic ways of of being able to take
care of themselves but then you got this
huge push on the other side of like
embrace your image embrace the obesity
embrace this embrace this and it's like
guys no
understand that if you allow that to
manipulate you and you're going to stay
at this weight 10 15 20 you might die
right you might die like it's just plain
and simple you will eventually die from
whatever disease you develop
or whatever problems come arise and if
you don't understand
that this is going to be a bad long-term
effect with you then you lost already
and and look
as a professional if i don't talk about
it then i'm not doing my part you know
and that's why i always tell people
coaches trainers like talk about it
don't be scared to talk about it because
i feel like sometimes people are scared
to talk about it because you want to get
attacked on social i don't care attack
me all you want you know and if anything
i'm going to bring the opposite spectrum
that i've been seeing and i've been
seeing a lot of people um fit shaming
there's a lot of people now on the
opposite side where they're constantly
fish shaming people they're attacking
people for being over fully fit and
telling them oh you're sending the wrong
message by being overly fit because you
should be that fit and
how about the people who are not that
fit it's like hold up so now being fit
and healthy is a problem it's like no no
no no yeah you definitely got something
to work with here and here
you have to work on and it's not to me
it's not to laugh make fun of that but
it's just like
what happens is i've and i've noticed a
lot of people who who've put themselves
in this position is because they're
dealing with a lot of insecurity they've
probably dealt with a lot of trauma in
their life they probably have tried
losing some weight they just didn't have
the right help or the right answers and
they gave up too early and then what
happens is they didn't feel accepted
they needed to feel accepted in a group
that's going to take them in they wanted
to be around friends that were going to
take them in and then those groups
started happening and that's where they
feel comfortable yeah but that group is
making you worse yeah it's only doing
you worse if you like the short clip you
can catch another one here or you can
catch the full episode right here
[Music]